la función continua g esta gráfica da
nos interesa el área bajo la curva entre
x igual a menos 7 y x igual a 7 y
estamos considerando usar las sumas de
riman para aproximar así que esta es el
área que nos interesa está de color azul
ordena las áreas de menor al inicio a
mayor al final ok
bueno esta es una captura de pantalla de
un ejercicio en khan academy en el que
ustedes simplemente pueden arrastrar y
acomodar cada uno de los recuadros pero
como ésta sólo es una captura de
pantalla no puedo arrastrarlos por lo
que voy a escribir los números para
ordenar los de menor a mayor uno será el
menor 3 será el mayor entonces pause en
el vídeo y traten de resolverlo ustedes
primero piensen en cuál de estos será el
menor cuál estará en medio y cuál será
el mayor okay veamos qué pasa con las
sumas de riman por la izquierda y por la
derecha analicemos cómo se ven y vamos a
compararlas con el área real
así que podemos hacer un cierto número
de subdivisiones arbitrariamente pero en
general los invito a que hagamos pocas y
no tienen que ser subdivisiones iguales
primero veamos la suma de riman por la
izquierda vamos a empezar en x igual a
menos 7 y queremos llegar hasta x igual
a 7 supongamos que este será el primer
rectángulo esta es nuestra primera
subdivisión como es una suma de riman
por la izquierda el valor de la altura
de la función será definida por el lado
izquierdo de cada una de esas
subdivisiones entonces si empezamos en x
menos 7 y aquí el valor de la función es
12 este es nuestro primer rectángulo
miren ya empezamos a ver que tendremos
una sobreestimación relativa al área
real ok la siguiente subdivisión empieza
aquí
esta es la altura de nuestro rectángulo
y recuerden no tienen que ser
subdivisiones iguales normalmente lo son
pero aquí haré una subdivisión desigual
para mostrarles que sí
siendo una suma de riman válida
nuevamente tenemos una sobreestimación
en donde el área que tratamos de
aproximar es menor al área de este
rectángulo
finalmente supongamos que la tercera
subdivisión empieza en x igual a 3 y si
usamos el lado izquierdo para definir la
altura de la subdivisión nuevamente
tenemos una sobreestimación así que la
suma de riman por la izquierda
claramente está sobreestimada está muy
claro porque la función nunca aumenta
sino que más bien disminuye e incluso
parece que se mantiene constante en
algunos puntos y para una función como
ésta el valor de la función en el lado
izquierdo de cada subdivisión será mayor
a cualquier otro valor de la función
sobre ese intervalo por lo que en este
caso tenemos toda esta área extra que es
parte de la sobreestimación toda esta
área es más grande que el área real que
tratamos de aproximar ahora pensemos en
la suma de riman por la derecha pero
esta vez haré algunas subdivisiones
diferentes supongamos que la primera
subdivisión va de menos 7 a menos 5 aquí
vamos a usar el lado derecho para
definir la altura entonces en g de menos
5 tenemos nuestro primer rectángulo y
ahora el lado derecho de nuestro
siguiente rectángulo lo vamos a definir
en cero ahí está esta vez voy a hacer
cuatro rectángulos de modo que a nuestra
tercera subdivisión la voy a poner en x
3 que sería justo aquí y finalmente
vamos a decir que nuestra cuarta
subdivisión llega a x igual a 7 pero
como estamos usando el lado derecho de
las subdivisiones porque recuerden que
esta es una suma de riman por la derecha
aquí el valor de la función sería algo
como esto así que ahora podemos ver que
para cualquiera de estas subdivisiones
todos los rectángulos están subestimados
respecto al área bajo la curva así que
la suma de riman por la derecha está
subestimada
eso es porque en este caso en particular
la función nunca aumenta sino que
disminuye o se mantiene constante
entonces si usamos el valor del lado
derecho de la función la subdivisión
será menor pues nunca será mayor a el
valor de la función en el resto de esta
subdivisión por lo que continuamente
estamos subestimando la función real
porque nos perdemos de toda esta área
que no estamos incluyendo por lo tanto
si queremos ordenar todo esto de menor a
mayor la menor es la suma de riman por
la derecha que está subestimada después
tenemos el área real bajo la curva que
es simplemente el área de la curva y
finalmente tenemos la suma de riman por
la izquierda que está sobreestimada y
con esto terminamos